[Applaudissements]
je vais commencer par vous raconter une
histoire
pour vous montrer qu'on a tous en nous
quelque chose de formidable
nous avons plein de ressources
formidables mais d'abord nous allons
voyager au japon à l'époque féodale le
shogun l'empereur du japon ayant
connaissance d'un mètre du thé pour sa
réputation l'invite à lui servir le thé
le maître du thé en chantier se rend au
palais impérial à l'époque pour pouvoir
rentrer au palais il fallait être vêtu
en samouraï alors notre maître du thé
vêtu de son nouvel habit au moment de
traverser le pont pour pénétrer dans
l'enceinte bouscule involontairement un
samouraï ce sens mouraille offensé se
retourne et s'écrit samouraï
tu m'a bousculé demain je demande
réparation prépare toi à mourir le
maître du thé confus s'excuse maintes et
maintes fois il ne peut se défiler
il est obligé de relever le défi alors
notre maître du thé embarrassé rentrer
dans l'enceinte du palais et se met à la
recherche d'un maître d'armes
puis au bout d'un certain temps il
retrouve un maître d'armes
réputé il lui explique la méprise du
matin et lui dit maître d'armes
je ne suis qu'un maître du thé je ne
connais rien dans les arts de la guerre
demain je dois me battre pourriez-vous
m'enseigner l'art de se battre et de
mourir dignement
le maître d'armes avec sa sagesse
réfléchi et lui dit avant de commencer
votre leçon je vous propose que vous me
servier le thé le maître du thé enchanté
s'exécute
il ouvre son baluchon sort sa nappe la
positionne sur la table sort chaque
ustensile et les poses avec maîtrise
il sort les arômes du thé allume le feu
sous la bouilloire
puis il prépare son mélange à ce moment
là il n'ya plus culotté qui existe la
bouilloire chantent heal infuse de thé
habité de tous ses sens prenant tout le
temps nécessaire est habité d'une
extrême sérénité
le maître du tg sert le thé aux maîtres
d'armes
à ce moment là chaque geste a un sens
ils sont tous les deux hors du temps de
l'harmonie de la paix s'en dégage le
maître du thé attend le maître d'armes
déguste prend son temps et lui dit mon
ami je n'ai rien à vous apprendre
demain quand vous allez sortir votre
arme pour vos bat vous allez repensé à
tout ce que vous venez de faire en votre
cérémonie du thé avec toute la maîtrise
et tout le bonheur que vous m'avez
apporté vous lèverez vote armes et quand
votre adversaire va s'approcher vous le
frapperait le maître du thé remercie le
maître d'armes
le lendemain à l'aube dans la prairie
face au soleil et aux samouraïs offenser
le maître du thé se met à repenser à
tout ce que lui avait dit le maître
d'armes
il s'imagine en train de servir le thé
il sort son arme il maîtrise comme s'il
était en train de servir le thé puis il
se met en garde il lève son arme
attendant son adversaire puis au bout
d'un certain temps il ouvre les yeux et
surpris ils voient tous loin le samoura
qui s'en fut un grand pas ce samouraï
s'était mis à penser
sa tête comment je peux battre un homme
qui dégage autant de sérénité de force à
se mettre en garde
nous avons tous été confrontés à des
défis à des combats comme le maître du
thé nous avons tous vécu des situations
d'inconfort qui nous ont pollué ou qui
nous polluent encore la vie nous avons
tous travaillé sans relâche pour
atteindre un objectif sans jamais
l'atteindre
nous sommes tous sortis de notre zone de
confort sortir déplacer nos limites pour
y revenir rapidement en sécurité nous
avons tous vécu des échecs sans en tirer
une once de positif nous avons tous
reproduits des échecs et non les répéter
répéter répéter maintes et maintes fois
ce nous c'est moi c'est peut-être vous
culpabilité honte colère dénigrement ont
pu associer à cet échec
je vais vous donner un exemple il ya
quelques années j'ai fait un championnat
du monde de ju-jitsu je réalisais un
rêve de gosse vous savez quand on est
gamin quand on est gosse on veut être
champions du monde
c'était mon rêve de gamin je voulais un
super héros avec des super pouvoirs
j'étais ce super héros alors comme tout
athlète je me suis entraîné sérieusement
et l'entraînement c'est très facile il
ya quatre choses il ya la partie
physique
la partie technique la partie
stratégique et tactique et la partie
préparation mentale
j'avais travaillé l'ensemble de ces
domaines
j'avais telle est la limite de ce que je
pouvais faire même si sur la préparation
mentale
j'aurais pu aller plus loin ça y est
j'étais prêt j'étais prêt à gravir
je pouvais aller sur le toit du monde
j'étais entraîné jusqu'au bout alors le
jour j arrive ça y est c'est la compet
le stade pierre de coubertin est plein à
craquer la foule scande nos prénoms
moi je combats le troisième jour deux
jours d'attenté alors
ce jour là juste avant d'aller
m'échauffer je vais dans les vestiaires
j'avoue mon sac
j'enfile mon kimono et je mets ma
ceinture et à ce moment là des pensées
négatives pas ce bout de plage des
attrapes trop de stress j'ai peur j'ai
des doutes
que va penser ma famille que va passer
mes amis est ce que je me suis
suffisamment traîné
je me souviens ne plus rien du tout
c'est le vide
alors je me parle je me parle je me
parle
puis mon frère et des amis passent et
les pensées négatives s'en vont c'était
la première victoire de la journée
un peu plus tard je gagne un premier
combat deuxième combat je me blesse très
gravement au coude le médecin va
m'arrêter je refuse je suis un super
héros donc je vais au combat
j'y vais je donne tout ce que j'ai tout
ce que je peux donner je le donne mais
je perds bon il me reste encore une
chance d'aller chercher une médaille la
place de 3 à la médaille de bronze
donc j'y vais je fais plusieurs combats
dans la journée
j'arrive enfin cette place de 3 ça y est
c'est le combat je peux aller chercher
cette médaille de bronze
et là je vois une image alors je la
trappe
je la croche jeu l'ancrant sur cette
image je me voyais tout donné mais je me
voyais perdre compliqué pour démarrer un
combat et comme une difficulté n'arrive
jamais seul sur ce combat
j'allais pas être face à un adversaire
mais face à deux adversaires
impossible mais pourtant c'est vrai le
premier pas permis israélien 22 ans
plusieurs fois médaillé mondial
je l'avais rencontrée lors de la finale
des championnats d'europe en salle est
difficile mais j'étais un super héros
donc possible le deuxième plus grand
plus balèze
plus tenaces plus agressif 44 ans plein
de combat dans les pattes
c'était moi deux contre un ça l'aide
compliqué sur ce combat
alors arrive ce qui doit arriver je
donne tout ce que j'ai sur ce combat
mais je perds vous imaginez tout ce qui
s'est passé dans ma tête à ce moment là
le toit du monde s'était écroulé mes
rêves des gamins évanoui et moi j'étais
en train de regarder mes adversaires
avec leurs médailles sur le podium
j'étais juste à côté à la place du con
ampleur
comme l'ont prouvé les sciences humaines
les plus particulièrement la psychologie
sportive
je venais de pratiquer l'auto sabordage
et l'auto handicap
en fait je m'étais entraîné sérieusement
et au dernier moment
mes peurs mes doutes mes craintes
mes croyances limitantes mais dragon
intérieure avait reçu rhji du passé
avait refait surface et avait pris le
pouvoir
et vous quel est votre championnat du
monde quelle que soit la pratique quelle
que soit la discipline quel que soit
votre objectif
quel est votre championnat du monde avec
du temps avec du travail sur moi j'ai
beaucoup appris de ce championnat du
monde
en fait je suis allé visiter les zones
donc que je voulais pas les voir j'ai
travaillé sur mes croyances limitantes
quand j'étais petit on me disait était
nul ces bons à rien tu vas jamais y
arriver
j'avais pas de compliments aujourd'hui
c'est réglé on est tous en nous
intérieurement constitué de différentes
parties
il ya une partie qui veut et gérer une
partie qui veut pas alors elles rentrent
en conflit
elle se bousculent elle s'adresse health
empêche de faire quelque chose à
l'intérieur c'est le bordel je vais vous
donner un exemple le soir quand je
rentre dans la maison j'ai envie de me
plonger dans le canapé
et puis à l'autre partie qu'il y ait au
fauteuil bosser et là je fais rien de
bien pour vous le dire d'une autre façon
nous sommes tous constitués de
différents personnages différents
archétypes
je fais référence à carole person dans
son héros intérieur tous ces personnages
ils ont tous des points forts et des
points faibles des ressources des
compétences et aussi des émotions alors
le premier personnage qui est en nous
c'est le dragon où les dragons ils
peuvent être tout petit comme ils
peuvent être très gros ce sont nos bêtes
noires
nos difficultés nos peurs et souvent ils
nous font faire des choses que l'on
n'aime pas ensuite en nous il y à
l'enfant intérieur l'innocent lui il vit
à l'instant présent
il nie le danger il nie la réalité il ne
vit que pour le plaisir que pour
s'amuser il est il vit pour réaliser ses
rêves
ensuite il y en nous celui qui a été
rejeté celui qui a été abandonné
c'est leur phelim il est tout seul pour
résoudre ces soucis ces problèmes les
seuls face à ces situations là et les
victimes de ses émotions
après nous trouvons en nous celui qui
vit l'injustice c'est le caliméro le
bouc émissaire en fait c'est le martyr
ce martyr il se sacrifie pour les autres
il accepte la souffrance il rêverait de
ses émotions et ses paroles pour pas
blesser son entourage après nous
trouvons le vagabond où le pèlerin lui
ils voyagent ils voyagent dans le monde
un monde extérieur ou un monde intérieur
il marche seul il aime son indépendance
il est en accord avec ses émotions après
nous trouvons le mage ou le sage vous
savez c'est celui qui est capable de
transformer tout ce qui est négatif en
positif
lui il a cette force cette sagesse il
apprend de tout tout et expérience tout
est apprentissage après le dernier
personnage c'est un que je connais très
bien vous en doutez c'est le combattant
s'il grellier lui il fonce il va au
combat il se pose pas de questions il
peut être un guerrier du bien ou de la
force obscure maîtrise ils contrôlent
les peurs les faiblesses et les émotions
c'est pas pour lui
alors pour revenir un bon championnat du
monde
quand je suis monté sur le tapis je suis
monté avec un seul personnage je suis
monté uniquement avec mon combattants
j'avais oublié l'ensemble des
personnages j'avais oublié de les faire
travailler les uns avec les autres main
dans la main à la réalisation de mon
objectif de mon rêve de gosse avec leurs
ressources leurs points faibles
leurs émotions je n'étais pas unis
ce soir par ce talk je tenais à vous
offrir ce cadeau que j'ai reçu des
championnats du monde j'ai pas une
médaille mais j'ai eu autre chose qui
est d'unir tous les personnages qui sont
en nous de les faire travailler ensemble
à la réalisation de votre rêve de mon
rêve est d'aller explorer tous ensemble
mais on donc où vos zones d'ombré
aujourd'hui je suis mon maître du thé et
vous pouvez être votre maître du thé
aujourd'hui je suis entraîneur des
équipes de france de ju jitsu j'entraîne
des athlètes de haut niveau et je suis
plus particulièrement chargé de leur
préparation mentale et nous sommes
champions du monde par équipes et
meilleures nations
alors nos échecs nos erreurs du passé
sont d'autant d'expériences
enrichissantes
il ya un puissant moteur de changement
au service de soi et d'autrui
il suffit d'être bon et bienveillant
avec soi même et pour terminer ce voyage
je vais vous lancé cette invitation
oser
c'est perdre pied momentanément ne pas
oser c'est perdre pied définitivement
alors soyez votre maître du thé merci
beaucoup